sin muy buenos días raúl pues cuando
quedan tan sólo 39 días para que se
celebren estas elecciones presidenciales
las palabras del presidente de la trama
han provocado una ola de reacciones a
todos los niveles empezando por el
senado donde el líder de la mayoría
misma con el decía que esta transición
por supuesto que va a ser pasiva
pacífica como se viene haciendo cada
cuatro años desde 1792 eso mismo
tuiteaba en su cuenta los demócratas
también han reaccionan reaccionado han
dicho que estas declaraciones son
peligrosas y que atentan contra la
democracia del país hemos visto también
la reacción de senadores republicanos de
su propio partido que ya han dicho que
no están de acuerdo con las palabras de
donald tan como el senador de florida
que ha dicho que la transición por
supuesto que será pacífica y lejos de
calmar las aguas raúl la secretaria de
prensa del presidente cale maquinal él
también ha dicho que está que el
presidente aceptará los resultados de
unas elecciones justas y cuando se le ha
preguntado que serán unas elecciones
justas ella ha contestado que lo que el
presidente crea que el proceso
el presidente crea que el proceso no ha
sido manipulado